مقاطع فيديو طريفه لياسمين عبد العزيز
وشيرين عبد الوهاب على انستجرام هاوس
باربي يصل الى الخليج عرض في السعوديه
ومنع في الكويت وانتقادات لمحمد منير بسبب
ميريام فارس اليكم الابرز باسبوع
[موسيقى]
بعد الكثير من الترقب بدا الاسبوع الماضي
عرض فيلم باربي في السعوديه والامارات
ومصر وذلك بالتزامن مع اعلان الاتجاه لمنع
عرضه في لبنان ومنع العرض رسميا في الكويت
ما فتح الباب امام ما وصف بالهجره العكسيه
لعدد من الكويتيين لمشاهده الفيلم في
السعوديه خلافا لما كان يحدث سابقا حيث
كان السعوديون يقصدون دولا خليجيه مجاوره
لمشاهده الافلام خلال سنوات حظر السينما
في المملكه واتهم رئيس لجنه الرقابه على
الافلام السينمائيه في الكويت لا في
السبيعي فيلم باربي بخش الاداب العامه
والتحريض على مخالفه النظام العام
والعادات والتقاليد بحسب تصريح نقلته عنه
وكاله الانباء الكويتيه كونان كما قال
وزير الثقافه اللبناني محمد المرتضى في
تصريح نقلته وكاله الانباء اللبنانيه
الرسميه الى فيلم باربي يتعارض مع القيم
الاخلاقيه والايمانيه ومع المبادئ الراسخه
في لبنان وعلقت المغنيه اللبنانيه الي
تصريحات وزير الثقافه اللبنانيه في منشور
لها على منصه اكس تويتر سابقا معتبره ان
المنع من اسخف القرارات التي تزيد من
رجعيه الدوله ومؤسساتها بحسب تعبيرها
ويواصل فيلم باربي تحقيق المزيد من
الايرادات القياسيه حول العالم في الوقت
الذي اعلن فيه المخرج المصري بترميم ان
فيلم بيت الروبي من بطوله كريم عبد العزيز
وكريم محمود عبد العزيز اصبح رسميا الاعلى
تحقيقا للايرادات من شباك التذاكر في
تاريخ السينما المصريه متفوقا بذلك على
فيلم كلى والجن المخرج ذاته ومن بطوله
احمد عز وكريم عبد العزيز
[موسيقى]
وتعدي عن شمالي اسمر مالك ومالك سنه
ومن السينما الى الاصدارات الموسيقيه
وانتقادات بعض المصريين على منصات التواصل
محمد منير بسبب الساحل الشمالي الذي تشارك
فيه الغناء مع ميريام فارس حيث لا يزال
البعض ياخذ موقفا سلبيا منها بسبب تصريح
سابق لها وجدوا فيه اساءه الى بلدهم رغم
توضيحها للتصريح في وقت لاحق واعتذارها
للشعب المصري وتجاوز عدد مشاهدات اغنيه
الساحل الشمالي لمنير وميريم الخمسه
ملايين مشاهده في خمسه ايام على موقع
يوتيوب وكان محمد منير قد احيا مؤخرا ليله
لا تنسى بحسب وصف متابعين على المنصات
التواصل في مهرجان العلمين الجديده في مصر
الى جانب الفنان حميد الشاعري وتستمر
فعاليات المهرجان حتى اواخر شهر اغسطس
الجاري
[موسيقى]
واخيرا حققت مقاطع فيديو طريفه نشرتها
الفنانه ياسمين عبد العزيز على الانستغرام
ظهرت فيها مع الفنانه شيرين عبد الوهاب
تفاعلا واسعا من محبين الفنانتين المثليين
وراى فيها البعض رساله طمانه لجمهور شيرين
بعد الشائعه التي طالتها مؤخرا